This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The podcast 20,000 Hertz tells stories about the world's most recognizable and interesting sounds. It is a great show that you should definitely subscribe to, and I'm pleased to present one of their episodes here today. It's all about these sounds, which almost need no introduction. From 20,000 Hertz, here is Dallas Taylor.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。播客节目《20,000赫兹》（20,000 Hertz）讲述了世界上最具辨识度和有趣的声音背后的故事。这是一个非常棒的节目，你绝对应该订阅它，我很高兴今天能在这里呈现他们的一期节目。这期节目全部关于这些几乎不需要介绍的声音。来自《20,000赫兹》的主持人达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）。
If you watch cartoons as a kid, you probably knew instantly that the sound you just heard was from Looney Toons. You probably also know that sound met Wily Coyote failed to catch the roadrunner. Again, it's pretty crazy how we can fill in the whole scene based solely on the sound effects, even without a single meat meat from the road runner. Wily Coyote started falling off cliffs in 1949. Yet we still hear that falling sound effect in modern cartoons, like Teen Titans. I wouldn't stand there if I were you. Titans. I wouldn't stand there if I were you. Here it is in Justice League Action. And here it is even in Family Guy. guy. Ow! It's been almost 70 years since the first Wily Coyote cartoon, and that sound, along with many other cartoon sounds, remains constant.
如果你小时候看过动画片，你大概一眼就能认出你刚才听到的声音来自《乐一通》（Looney Toons）。你大概也知道，那个声音伴随着歪心狼（Wily Coyote）未能抓住追风路跑鸟（Road Runner）。话说回来，真挺疯狂的，仅凭音效我们就能脑补出整个场景，甚至连路跑鸟的一声“哔哔”都没有。歪心狼从1949年开始就一直在从悬崖上掉下去。然而，我们至今仍能在现代动画片中听到那个下落的音效，比如《少年泰坦》（Teen Titans）。如果我是你，我才不会站在那里。泰坦。如果我是你，我才不会站那儿。在《正义联盟行动》（Justice League Action）里能听到。甚至在《恶搞之家》（Family Guy）里也能听到。哎哟！距离第一部歪心狼动画片问世已经快70年了，那个声音以及许多其他的动画音效依然如故。
The beauty and the joy of cartoon animation is that the characters do not have to obey the laws of physics. They also don't have to obey the laws of logic, and therefore sound doesn't have to obey those laws either. That's Mark Mangini, an Oscar-winning sound designer who works with the Formosa Group. I don't very often get to talk about my early days in cartoons. That's Mark Mangini, an Oscar-winning sound designer who works with the Formosa group. I don't very often get to talk about my early days in cartoons. Mark doesn't get a lot of questions about cartoons because he has an impressive resume
动画艺术的美妙和快乐在于角色不必遵守物理定律。它们也不必遵守逻辑定律，因此声音也不必遵守这些定律。说话的是马克·曼吉尼（Mark Mangini），一位曾获奥斯卡奖的音效设计师，目前供职于 Formosa Group。我很少有机会谈论我早年做动画的经历。说话的是马克·曼吉尼，一位曾获奥斯卡奖的音效设计师，供职于 Formosa Group。我很少有机会谈论我早年做动画的经历。马克不常被问及关于动画的问题，因为他拥有令人瞩目的履历。
designing sounds for Hollywood blockbusters. I've worked on 142 live-action films. Most recently Blade Runner 2049, Mad Max Fury Road, which I want an Oscar for, and I'm very proud of. Warrior, Gremlins, Four Star Trek, a die hard, a lethal weapon, the Green Mile. But before Mark did sound for films, he worked for one of the most famous cartoon studios in the world. My first job in sound was at Hanna Barbera Studios in their sound department.
曾为好莱坞大片设计音效。我参与过142部真人电影。最近的有《银翼杀手2049》（Blade Runner 2049）、让我赢得奥斯卡奖并为此深感自豪的《疯狂的麦克斯：狂暴之路》（Mad Max Fury Road）、《勇士》（Warrior）、《小精灵》（Gremlins）、四部《星际迷航》（Star Trek）、一部《虎胆龙威》（Die Hard）、一部《致命武器》（Lethal Weapon）、《绿里奇迹》（The Green Mile）。但在马克为电影做音效之前，他曾在世界上最著名的动画工作室之一工作。我的第一份音效工作是在汉娜巴伯拉工作室（Hanna Barbera Studios）的音效部门。
I started as a track reader, which is a subset of sound editing where you're charged with transcribing the recordings of the voices so that the animators no-went to open and close the mouths of the characters. Just keep your eye on the ball, Bonnie Boy. That led to subsequent promotions to becoming a sound effects editor in that department at Hanabar Barbera, and an apprenticeship with a number of really amazingly gifted sound editors. Back then, this was 1976.
我最初是一名对轨员（track reader），这是音效剪辑的一个分支，你的职责是转录对白录音，以便动画师知道何时张开和闭上角色的嘴巴。盯紧那个球，邦尼小子。这促使我随后晋升为汉娜巴伯拉动画部门的音效剪辑师，并师从多位真正极其才华横溢的音效剪辑师进行学徒培训。当时是1976年。
I didn't know anyone who was called a sound designer, but I would argue that everything that we were doing at Hanabar Barbarra was every bit as designed as maybe something more profound that was being heard in a motion picture. Mark worked on some of Hanabarbara's most famous cartoons. The Flintstones. Come on, Bonnie. Let's go. Some Huckleberry hounds.
我不认识任何被称为音效设计师的人，但我敢说，我们在汉娜巴伯拉所做的每一件事，其设计感绝不亚于电影中听到的那些可能更深刻的东西。马克参与了汉娜巴伯拉一些最著名的动画片。原始人（The Flintstones）。来吧，邦尼。我们走。还有《哈克贝利猎犬》（Huckleberry Hound）。
Far to far, my aunt. Oh, did I have to make up a tap, Bob? I was trying to. All right. A whole raft of Scoooby-dos. Scooby-doo! Where are you? The super friends. They're a mission to fight injustice,
远方，我的姑妈。哦，我得编个拍子吗，鲍勃？我正试着呢。好吧。还有一大堆《史酷比》（Scooby-Doo）。史酷比！你在哪儿？《超级朋友》（Super Friends）。他们的使命是打击不义，
to write that which is wrong, and to serve all mankind. And my personal favorite because it starred Mel Blank, Captain Caveman. Captain Caveman! Long before Mark worked for Hannah Barbera, and even before Wiley Coyote was falling off cliffs, Walt Disney made history with Steamboat Willie in 1928. This was the first cartoon with synchronized picture and sound. Walt and Roy and Ab-Iworks themselves would be the sound effects guys in their live orchestral recording sessions for those early
纠正错误，为全人类服务。还有我个人最喜欢的，因为主演是梅尔·布兰克（Mel Blanc）的《石器小超人》（Captain Caveman）。石器小超人！早在马克为汉娜巴伯拉工作之前，甚至在歪心狼从悬崖上掉下去之前，华特·迪士尼（Walt Disney）在1928年凭借《威利号汽船》（Steamboat Willie）创造了历史。这是第一部实现画面与声音同步的动画片。华特、罗伊和阿布·艾克斯（Ab Iworks）亲自担任那些早期《威利号汽船》现场管弦乐队录音过程中的音效师。
steamboat willies. In the early days before there was multi-track recording or mixing, you had to perform the sound effects live with the orchestra in one straight pass. So these sound effects guys had to assemble props, put them in front of microphones, and perform anything that they could acoustically live and ensync with the orchestra. Music and sound effects had to be performed at the same time in the same space. Musical instruments were used to make the effects because they were easy to find and easy to manipulate.
在没有多轨录音或混音的早期，你必须在一次连续的录制过程中与管弦乐队现场配合表演音效。所以这些音效师必须收集道具，把它们放在麦克风前面，用原声现场表演任何他们能做出的、与管弦乐队同步的声音。音乐和音效必须在同一时间和同一空间内同时表演。乐器被用来制作音效，因为它们很容易找到且易于操纵。
In this Tom and Jerry clip, the sound of a frying pan hitting Tom's face is played by a simple crash. And that falling whistle from the beginning of the episode, that's played on a slide whistle. The percussionist would probably have it as part of their kit, and it was just a natural to convey going up... or down. You could manipulate them in any one of a number of ways for a quickly or very slowly. Sound effects played by musical instruments became an iconic part of all cartoons. Then new audio technology in the 1930s allowed sound editors to add sound effects after recording the orchestra.
在这段《猫和老鼠》（Tom and Jerry）剪辑中，平底锅击中汤姆脸部的声音是由一次简单的镲声来演奏的。而片头那个下落的滑音，是用滑音哨（slide whistle）演奏的。打击乐手可能会把它作为自己乐器套件的一部分，用它来表现上升……或下降，这是再自然不过的事了。你可以用多种方式中的任何一种来快速或非常缓慢地操纵它们。由乐器演奏的音效成为了所有动画片标志性的部分。接着，20世纪30年代的新音频技术允许音效剪辑师在录制管弦乐队之后添加音效。
They could use any prop to make a sound, but often still shows musical instruments. And because sound effects and music were tightly linked, they worked together to create unique soundscapes. Listen to this audio clip from the very first Bugs Bunny cartoon called Porquies Hair Hunt. In it, you can get an idea of how effects and music can come together. Don't get them, Jero! Get that, Rero! I'll get it! The sounds for Porquies' hairhunt were created by an editor named Treg Brown.
他们可以使用任何道具来制造声音，但通常仍然会使用乐器。而且由于音效和音乐紧密相连，它们协同工作，创造出独特的音景。听听这段来自第一部名为《波基的寻发之旅》（Porky's Hare Hunt）的兔八哥（Bugs Bunny）动画片的音频剪辑。从中你可以体会到音效和音乐是如何结合在一起的。抓住他们，杰罗！抓住那个，雷罗！我去抓！《波基的寻发之旅》中的声音是由一位名叫特雷格·布朗（Treg Brown）的剪辑师创作的。
Treg worked on Looney Tunes for decades, and created many of the iconic cartoon sounds we still know today. Once we divorced ourselves from the need to record live to picture, Treg had this fundamental understanding of how to decontextualize a sound, how to take the sound of your finger in a coke bottle and make that the sound of the Roadrunner, Tung Flip. Pfff. Or why the sound of an inertia starter,
特雷格为《乐一通》工作了数十年，创作了许多至今我们仍熟知的标志性动画声音。一旦我们摆脱了必须对着画面进行现场录音的需求，特雷格就对如何将声音去语境化有了这种根本上的理解——如何把你的手指插进可口可乐瓶子里的声音变成路跑鸟的声音，噗，啵。或者为什么惯性起动机的声音——
the sound of this motor that makes a biplane engine start, why that's the sound of a spinning Tasmanian devil. He learned to be a genius at taking sounds out of one context and placing them in another context. And that's what made him so amazing. And when you listen to those looney-tunes shorts, there isn't a lot of cartoon sound in those. There isn't a lot of comedic sound. It's all blood and his ability to take a sound from somewhere else and put it where it didn't
也就是让双翼飞机引擎启动的马达声——为什么那是旋转的塔斯马尼亚恶魔（Tasmanian Devil）的声音。他学会了成为将声音从一个语境中剥离并放入另一个语境中的天才。这就是他如此了不起的原因。当你听那些《乐一通》短片时，里面的动画声音其实并不多。喜剧音效并不多。全靠他有能力把别处的声音拿来，放到不属于它的地方，
belong, creating this bizarre juxtaposition that made it funny. And I don't think there was anybody better than he was at that. Around the same time, Treg was working at Warner Brothers. William Hanna and Joseph Barbera were creating the Tom and Jerry cartoons at MGM. Mark's mentor, Greg Watson, was a sound editor on those early Tom and Jerry cartoons. When I met him as he was in his 60s, late in his career, but immensely proud to be still working in cartoons, he still saw it as an art form. Something he's very proud of. And he would never take credit for anything unless I asked him, he'd Greg where did this come from? And he said, oh, I remember back. And 51, when Bill did this one funny scene with Jerry, and we needed a funny sound,
创造出这种滑稽的奇异并置。我不认为有谁在这方面比他更出色。大约在特雷格为华纳兄弟（Warner Brothers）工作的同一时期，威廉·汉娜（William Hanna）和约瑟夫·巴伯拉（Joseph Barbera）正在米高梅（MGM）创作《猫和老鼠》动画片。马克的导师格雷格·沃森（Greg Watson）就是早期《猫和老鼠》动画片的音效剪辑师。当我遇到他时，他已经60多岁了，处于职业生涯的晚期，但对于自己仍然在从事动画工作感到无比自豪，他依然将之视为一门艺术。这是他非常引以为傲的事。而且他绝不会居功，除非我问他：“格雷格，这个声音是哪来的？”他说：“哦，我记起来了，在51年，当比尔（Bill）和杰瑞拍了这个搞笑的场景，我们需要一个搞笑的声音，
and we thought it would be good to do this, he was a man that was just thrilled to be a part of the process. Bill Hanna and Joseph Barbera eventually created their own studio. And during their 30 years of making cartoons, they created a massive library of totally classic sounds. I think they're unique, at least because of their own merit, they're just silly, so many
我们觉得这样做会很好。”他是一个仅仅能成为这个过程的一部分就感到欣喜若狂的人。比尔·汉娜和约瑟夫·巴伯拉最终创建了自己的工作室。在他们制作动画片的30年里，他们创造了一个庞大的全经典音效库。我认为它们是独特的，至少凭它们自身的价值而言，它们就是很滑稽，其中有许多声音，
of them, even out of the context of the cartoon, just sound like that's just the silliest thing I've ever heard. But then, within the context of the cartoons and the way that they were used and the life that they brought to those cartoons, they just get better, basking in the limelight of the animation. For instance, this sound is pretty silly on its own. Now imagine Tom hanging from his whiskers in the unavoidable fall as each one is plucked from his cheeks. There were hundreds of familiar sounds like this created at Hanaparbara Studios.
即使脱离了动画片的语境，听起来也只是“这是我听过最滑稽的东西”。但随后，在动画片的语境中，以及它们被使用的方式、它们为这些动画片注入的生命力，让它们在动画的聚光灯下沐浴着，变得更加出色。例如，这个声音本身就挺滑稽。现在想象一下汤姆挂在胡须上那不可避免的下落，每根胡须都从他的脸颊上被拔掉。汉娜巴伯拉工作室创作了数百种这样熟悉的声音。
They had such a signature quality to themselves that it made them stand out as a unique piece of quality artwork, sonic artwork. In the 1960s, Hannah Barbarra started selling their sound library. Other production companies like Warner Brothers use these sounds to this day. The popularity of the Hannah Barbarra sound library has given cartoons in almost universal sound language, but Markfield feels some sounds are overused. I was on a one-man campaign to eradicate head take. It was this in name noise that was again I think a recording accident that you would use whenever a character all of a sudden caught themselves in the
它们具有如此鲜明的个人特色，使其脱颖而出，成为一件独特的优质艺术品、声音艺术品。20世纪60年代，汉娜巴伯拉开始出售他们的音效库。诸如华纳兄弟等其他制作公司至今仍在沿用这些声音。汉娜巴伯拉音效库的普及赋予了动画片几乎通用的声音语言，但马克觉得有些声音被过度使用了。我曾发起过一场旨在根除“head take”（惊吓声）的单人运动。那是一种内心的噪音，我认为这又是一次录音意外，每当角色突然发现自己陷入思考或经历某种诡异的事情时就会使用它，而且被严重过度使用了。你有没有注意到动画片角色奔跑时的声音是怎样的？
midst of thinking or experiencing something bizarre and it was way overused. And did you ever notice how it sounds when a cartoon character runs? Mark's not a fan of that one either. That running sound was called Blob Gallup. And again, a sound that was, I felt overused and I tried to not use it as often as I could. It's illogical, but I tried not to use it as often as possible.
马克也不是那个声音的粉丝。那种奔跑的声音被称为 Blob Gallup（滑稽奔跑声）。同样，这是一个我觉得被过度使用了的声音，我尽量少用它。这虽不合逻辑，但我尽量尽可能少地使用它。
It's a testament to its effectiveness. But even in 1976, I was training into an elitist, I suppose. Hello, Barra Singh. Of course, there are plenty of sounds that Mark loves, like a tiptoeing xylophone. Oh, that's a classic sound. I have actually used that sound. I did the two Flintstone live-action movies, and I did use it in that, because that was a sound that Brian Levant, the director and I just loved,
这是对其有效性的证明。但即使在1976年，我想我也在把自己训练成一个精英主义者。你好，巴拉·辛格。当然，有很多声音是马克喜欢的，比如蹑手蹑脚的木琴声。哦，那是个经典声音。我实际上用过那个声音。我制作了两部《摩登原始人》（The Flintstones）真人电影，我在里面用了它，因为那是导演布赖恩·莱万特（Brian Levant）和我都很喜欢的声音，
and we just couldn't avoid using that. Hi. My favorite was the Jetson Spaceships. And I never found out what those were made for. I tried to deconstruct them. I asked around the studio if they know who made them and nobody knew, but that sound always brings a smile to my face. Sadly, some of these old techniques have been lost, but remember, this was a busy studio,
我们简直无法避免不去使用它。嗨。我最喜欢的是杰森一家（Jetson）的飞船。我从来没搞清楚那些声音是用什么做出来的。我试着去解构它们。我在工作室里到处打听是否有人知道是谁制作的，但没有人知道，不过那个声音总是能让我脸上露出微笑。遗憾的是，其中一些老技术已经失传了，但请记住，这是一个忙碌的工作室，
and everyone was focused on getting the work done on time and getting cartoons on air. It was a real machine. It always started with track reading. This is Ballpoint PUNS, line one. Good evening, ladies and gentlemen. The thing which is to say the voices would be assembled in a studio with a script and storyboards. The director of that show would walk the talent through the recording session so that you captured all the voices speaking all the lines that you needed for that particular episode. Just watch the birdie! Get it on your head. OK.
每个人都专注于按时完成工作并将动画片播映。这真是一台机器。它总是从对轨（track reading）开始。这是圆珠笔笑话（Ballpoint PUNS），第一行。大家晚上好。也就是说，配音演员们会带着剧本和故事板聚集在工作室里。该节目的导演会带领配音演员完成录音过程，以便你捕捉到该特定集数所需的所有角色台词。只要看着那只小鸟！把它弄到你头上。好的。
Then the animators would go off and then draw the characters doing these things. Then a month later, all the animation would come back in short roles of completed scenes. Then we in the editorial department would assemble them in their storyboard order and then cut them down to show length. There wasn't like animatics in between like we have in live action. We disemble a show and then cut sound to it.
然后动画师们会离开去画出做这些动作的角色。一个月后，所有的动画都会以一卷卷完成场景的短片形式返回。接着，我们在剪辑部门会按照它们在故事板中的顺序将它们组装起来，然后剪辑到节目所需的长度。不像真人电影那样中间有什么动态故事板（animatics）。我们是组装好一个节目，然后为其剪辑声音。
When Mark was working with Hannah Barbera, they didn't have a department dedicated to creating new sounds. If he wanted an effect that wasn't in the library, he had to find it himself. You were just kind of on your own. I was the most adventurous, especially for the super friends. I would go across the hall to talk to the two composers, Paul DeCourt and Hoit Curtin, and I'd ask them for musical sounds and especially synthesizer sounds. So they would give me long recorded stretches of just weird noises they'd make with their synthesizers.
当马克在汉娜巴伯拉工作时，他们没有专门负责创造新声音的部门。如果他想要一个音效库里没有的效果，他必须自己去寻找。你基本上只能靠自己。我是最喜欢冒险的，尤其是为了《超级朋友》。我会穿过大厅去跟两位作曲家保罗·德库尔特（Paul DeCourte）和霍伊特·柯廷（Hoit Curtin）谈谈，向他们索要音乐声音，尤其是合成器声音。所以他们会给我提供长段的、录制好的、仅用合成器发出的奇怪噪音。
And they would always be used as the science fiction components if I had a spaceship or a flying saucer in an episode. That's what I used the electronic sounds for because that felt futuristic to me. And if Mark couldn't find the sound he wanted, he had to create it, even if he had to use his own voice. If you can't find it, you do it with your voice. It's the easiest tool to manipulate. You have total control over it. I use it for creatures, and animals, and funny noises. I did a lot of Gremlins voices for the Gremlins movies. Have fun.
如果某一集中我有飞船或飞碟，这些声音总是会被用作科幻元素。这就是我使用电子声音的原因，因为这让我感觉很具有未来感。如果马克找不到他想要的声音，他必须自己创造，哪怕必须使用他自己的声音。如果你找不到，就用你自己的声音来做。这是最容易操纵的工具。你对它拥有完全的控制权。我用它来表现生物、动物和滑稽的噪音。我为《小精灵》系列电影做了很多小精灵的声音。玩得开心。
Pretty neat, huh? What is this with us? Holy fadget. It's just something where you feel the character inside of yourself and you think, I can do this better. And you just do it. Mark also went on to work on some of the most classic animated films. I did Beauty and the Beast.
挺整洁的，对吧？我们这是怎么了？天哪。这只是一种你在内心感受到角色，然后心想“我能做得更好”的感觉。然后你就直接做了。马克后来还参与了一些最经典的动画电影的制作。我做过《美女与野兽》（Beauty and the Beast）。
They can sing, they can dance. After all this, this is France. Aladdin, I can show you the world. Shining, shimmering, splendid. And the Lion King. The circle of light. And the red moon of the sun. Mark's experiences with animated films were different I'm a man who's a soul. Mark's experiences with animated films were different from the grind of televised cartoons.
它们会唱歌，它们会跳舞。毕竟，这是法国。《阿拉丁》（Aladdin），我可以向你展示这个世界。闪耀、波光粼粼、壮丽。《狮子王》（The Lion King）。生命之环。以及太阳的红月亮。马克参与动画电影的经历与——我是一个有灵魂的人。马克参与动画电影的经历与电视动画的枯燥劳累有所不同。
If nothing else, you get much better schedules. You usually get the time to design and create something that no one's ever heard before. Another sort of unique distinction is that you have the option to create sound first and then have animation be done to what you did. It's not that often that we get to actually drive the image.
最起码，你的档期要好得多。你通常有时间去设计和创造一些别人从未听过的新东西。另一个独特的区别是，你可以选择先制作声音，然后让动画去配合你所做的事情。我们能真正主导画面的情况其实并不多。
And on the Disney animated films and the Pixar films and the Dreamworks films and others, they're smart enough to know the value of sound and how it can be the inspiration to the artist to draw something that they might not otherwise have drawn. For example, in Beauty and the Beast, Bell's dad was this inventor and he had built that funny acts-chopping machine. That was a sound that we made before animation. Let's give it a try. It does. It does.
在迪士尼动画电影、皮克斯（Pixar）电影、梦工厂（DreamWorks）电影和其他影片中，他们足够聪明，深知声音的价值，以及它如何能够启发艺术家画出他们平时可能画不出来的东西。例如，在《美女与野兽》中，贝尔（Belle）的父亲是个发明家，他建造了那个滑稽的砍斧机器。那是我们在动画制作之前就做好的声音。让我们试一试。确实。确实。
It does. It does. It does. It does. It does. It does. It does. It does.
确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。
确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。
It does. It does. It does. It does. It does. It does. design, that's when you get to let your imagination run wild. You can see a picture from a storyboard, and then you just get to dream up what it might sound like. And that's just gold for a sound designer when you're sort of allowed to design unfettered. With all the cable channels and streaming services available today, there's more animation than ever before. So how does sound design work in modern cartoons, and which iconic sounds are still used today?
确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。确实。设计，那才是你让想象力尽情驰骋的时候。你可以看到故事板上的一幅画，然后你就可以梦想出它听起来会是什么样子。对于音效设计师来说，当你被允许无拘无束地进行设计时，这简直就是黄金。随着当今所有有线频道和流媒体服务的出现，动画比以往任何时候都多。那么，现代动画中的音效设计是如何运作的？今天仍然在使用哪些标志性的声音？
We'll get to all of that when 20,000 Hertz on 99% of visible continues. If you haven't watched a cartoon in years, it might surprise you that sounds from decades ago are still being used today. I used the older set effects quite a bit still. The Hanna Barbaria library, the Warner Brothers library, it's still kind of the go-to for certain gags and certain shows. That's Heather Olson, an Emmy-nominated sound designer for animation. She works at Advanced Audio.
当《20,000赫兹》在 99% Invisible 中继续播出时，我们会讲到所有这些。如果你已经多年没看动画片了，你可能会惊讶于几十年前的声音至今仍在使用。我至今仍会经常使用较旧的音效。汉娜巴伯拉音效库、华纳兄弟音效库，对于某些特定的搞笑桥段和某些节目来说，它们仍然是首选。说话的是海瑟·奥尔森（Heather Olson），一位获得过艾美奖提名的动画音效设计师。她供职于 Advanced Audio。
I'm working on Star vs. The Forces of Evil for Disney XD, trolls the beat goes on, and spirit writing free for Netflix. Hey! You'll say Adamy, huh? I worked on the fairly odd parents. Tough puppy. Bunsen is a beast. Big goat, banana cricket for Nickelodeon.
我正在为迪士尼 XD 频道（Disney XD）的《星际大战：邪恶势力》（Star vs. The Forces of Evil）、《魔发精灵：节奏延续》（Trolls: The Beat Goes On!）以及 Netflix 的《马背上的自由精神》（Spirit Riding Free）工作。嘿！你会说亚当语吗，哈？我曾参与过《奇幻精灵父母》（The Fairly OddParents）、《特工老爹》（T.U.F.F. Puppy）、《本森是头野兽》（Bunsen Is a Beast）、尼克儿童频道（Nickelodeon）的《大山羊与香蕉蟋蟀》。
Yeah! Big gop, banana cricket! I also worked on the adventures of Puss & Boots for Netflix. I am Puss & Boots! Gravity Falls for Disney XD. Rest assured, there's a perfectly logical explanation. And the Boondocks for Sony. Chop, chop, chop, chop!
耶！大山羊、香蕉蟋蟀！我还为 Netflix 参与了《穿靴子的猫的冒险》（The Adventures of Puss in Boots）。我就是穿靴子的猫！为迪士尼 XD 的《怪诞小镇》（Gravity Falls）。请放心，这背后有一个完全合乎逻辑的解释。以及为索尼制作的《祖宗小栈》（The Boondocks）。切，切，切，切！
Heather is an expert in modern cartoon sound design. Cartoon sound effects are different from live action sound effects because with live action you start with production sound. You're recording a picture and the recording the audio at the same time wherever the actors are. So if they're on a street, you have cars going by. It wasn't a cartoon. If you're doing a street scene you have cars going by, it was in a cartoon, if you're doing a street scene, all I get is dialogue, it's just the actors
海瑟是现代动画音效设计的专家。动画音效与真人电影音效不同，因为真人电影是从制作期声音（production sound）开始的。你在录制画面的同时也在录制音频，无论演员身处何地。所以如果他们在街上，你就会听到车流驶过。这不是动画片。如果你在做一个街景，你会有车流驶过；而在动画片中，如果你在做一个街景，我得到的只有对白，只有被录下来的演员的声音，我得以一张白纸起步。我不需要试图掩盖制作背景音，我能得到对白，并围绕它创造一个世界。参与动画制作既是最好的事情，也是最糟糕的事情，因为你不需要试图掩盖任何东西，但你又一无所有，所以你必须在脑海中思考——
who are recorded, and I get to start with a blank slate. I don't have to try to hide production backgrounds, I get to get the dialogue, and I get to create a world around it. It's kind of the best thing, and the worst thing at the same time to work on a cartoon, because you're not trying to hide anything, but you have nothing to start with, so in your head,
这听起来会是什么样？很像马克在汉娜巴伯拉的时光，海瑟拿到的是一部制作完成的动画片，并经常从现成的音效库中添加音效。这包括许多来自汉娜巴伯拉和华纳兄弟音效库的声音。以下是她最喜欢的一些。它被称为“管状闷响音效”（Tube Thunk Sound Effect）。我想每个人都知道这个声音听起来像谁。也许不知道它叫什么，但就是那个声音，
you have to think what would this sound like? Much like Mark's time at Hanabar Barra, Heather gets a fully animated show and often adds sound effects from a ready-made library of sounds. This includes many from the Hanabar Barra and Warner Bros. libraries. Here are some of her favorites. It's called the Tube Thunk Sound Effect. I think everybody knows who this sounds like. Maybe not what it's called, but it's that sound,
比如当一个角色把头卡在罐子里时，你会听到那个闷响。我喜欢那个老声音。它非常清晰地传达出“我的头卡在这个罐子里了，而且再也拔不出来了”。我也喜欢所有旧的奔跑声音。我一直在使用木琴闪烁声（xylophone blink）。
like when a character gets your head stuck in a jar, you hear that funk. I love that old sound. It's just so clearly conveys, my head is stuck in this jar, and it's not coming out again. And I also love all the old running sounds. And I'm using the xylophone blink all the time.
我认为这些声音之所以一直留在每个人的脑海中并在每个节目中出现，是因为那是我们开始理解的语言。所以当有人眨眼时，此时你多少会期望听到那个木琴声。当然，海瑟也会使用下落的滑音哨。我想在我们的音效库里，它被称为炸弹下落，但这是一回事。我的意思是，那是每个人都知道的另一种语言。由于她参与的一些节目更加现实，海瑟希望我们听到角色四处移动并与他们的世界互动的声音，有点像真人电影。
Those sounds I think have just persisted in everybody's mind and in every show because that's the language that we've started to understand. So when someone blinks, you kind of expect to hear that xylophone at this point. And of course, Heather uses the falling whistle. I think in our side of X-Liber, it's called bomb drop, but it's the same thing. I mean, that's another piece of the language that everybody knows. Since some of the show she works on are more realistic, Heather wants us to hear the sounds of the characters moving around and interacting with their world, kind of like a live-action movie.
拟音部门（Foley department）真正赋予了节目生命。他们录制脚步声、各种物品、角色的触碰声，我们称之为道具。他们负责更多微小的声音，拥有拟音制作的音效库真是太棒了，因为这样你就不会听到同样的脚步声一遍又一遍地出现。它们真的让声音听起来更真实。就像过去一样，如果你找不到某个声音，你就得自己创造。我为音效实际录制和制作过的比较奇怪的事情之一是，我们在《机器人怪物》（Robot Monster）中有一个情节，每个人都在一个拥挤的餐厅里，所以这本该是一群人对某种东西感到恶心反胃的人群声音。这并不是那种我可以在音效库里随手找到的效果。
The Foley department really brings a show to life. They record footsteps, things, characters, touch, which we call props. They do more of the smaller sounds, and it's great to have fully do that step of library because then you're not hearing the same footsteps over and over. They really make it sound more real. And just like in the past, if you can't find a sound, you have to make it. One of the stranger things I've actually recorded and done myself for a sound effect is we had a bit in robot monster where everyone was in a crowded restaurant, so it was supposed to be this crowd of people gagging and grossed out by something. And that's not exactly an effect I had to sit around my library.
所以我抓了办公室周围的一群人，我们录下了自己用各种不同方式作呕的声音。然后我把它们拼凑成了一群人。有时，将多个声音层层叠加是创造新事物的最佳方式。你可能想不到的奇特组合——我可没发明这个——动物和引擎是一个非常棒的组合。你在引擎声下面放进动物的咆哮声、低吼声，这真的能为画面注入生命力。
So I grabbed a bunch of people around the office and we recorded ourselves gagging in lots of different ways. And then I kind of pieced it all together into a crowd. Sometimes layering multiple sounds together is the best way to create something new. An odd combination that you might not expect, and I did not invent this, Animals and Engines is a really great one. You put animal roars under engines, growls, it really kind of brings a view of the life.
很多节目都这样做，但《星球大战》（Star Wars）里的钛战机（Tie Fighters）绝对是在它们呼啸而过时，在下方加入了一些低吼声。直接拨打这四个五。哦，是的。这太棒了。灵感。海瑟拥有的另一个选择是采用经典的音效库声音并改变其音调（pitch）来创造新的效果。以这个动画弹簧音效（boing sound effect）为例。她可以把那个声音的音调调高或调低。
A lot of shows do it, but Star Wars, definitely the tie fighters, there's some growls under there as they go by. Directly phone one of these four five. Oh, yeah. It's fantastic. Inspiration. Another option Heather has is to take a classic library sound and change its pitch to make a new effect. Take this cartoon boing sound effect. She can pitch that sound up or down.
海瑟在制作动画时使用了大量经典的非字面声音（non-literal sounds），但有些现代动画比滑稽闹剧更现实。她的选择真的取决于节目。所以，特别是在我们接手新节目时，我们会做所谓的“审片定位”（spotting the show），客户会进来，我们一起观看，然后讨论他们希望在什么地方加入什么声音，以及节目的整体感觉，比如它会是一个像《马背上的自由精神》那样相对现实的节目，还是像《奇幻精灵父母》那样非常具有动画感的节目？这样我就能轻松避开整个实验室。《奇幻精灵父母》教会了我如何说动画语言。
Heather uses a lot of classic non-literal sounds while working on cartoons, but some modern cartoons are more realistic than slapstick. Her choices really depend on the show. So especially when we get a new show, we'll do what we call spotting the show, where the clients come in and we watch it together, and we kind of talk about what they'd like where, and just the overall feel of the show, like is it going to be kind of a realistic show, like spirit, or is it going to be really cartoony, like fairly odd parents? So I'll be able to dodge the whole lab in an easy way. Fairly odd parents taught me how to speak cartoon.
没有适当的防护装备，我是绝对不会靠近那东西的。这简直就是不间断的动画、动画、动画。那种像精灵般的小声音在哪里？它感觉更像是你在拍一部电影，你知道的，有女孩们在田野里的马。由于《马背上的自由精神》比《奇幻精灵父母》这样的动画有更多自然的声音，海瑟需要一些新的声音。我们弄了一个全新的马匹音效库，因为在那部节目中，有三个角色是马，所以没有配音演员为它们配音，
I'm not going near that thing without the appropriate protective gear. It's just non-stop cartoon, cartoon, cartoon. Where's the little like spirit? It feels more like you're making a movie with, you know, horses out in the fields with girls. Because Spirit Riding Free has more natural sounds than a cartoon like Fairly Odd Parents, Heather needed some new sounds. We got a whole new horse library because in that show, there's three characters who are horses, so there are no actors voicing them,
而且它们每个人都有不同的个性，所以我们必须为每匹马找到不同的叫声。但即使是《马背上的自由精神》有时也需要一剂复古动画音效。很多时候，人们带着他们的节目来到这里说：“我不想用那些旧的汉娜巴伯拉声音，我想做完全不同的东西”，但他们的动画方式其实是传统的。所以当你为之配上新声音时，就会感觉不对劲，很多时候他们最终还是会回去使用旧的音效。谈到动画音效设计，马克和海瑟都认为这种媒介突破了创造力的边界。
and they each have a different personality, so we had to find different vocals for each of the horses. But even Spirit writing free still sometimes needs a dose of the vintage cartoon sounds. A lot of times people will come in with their show and say, I don't want to use those old Hanna Barbera sounds, I want to do something completely different, but they've kind of animated the traditional way. So when you put new sounds to that, it just feels wrong, and a lot of times they eventually go back to using the older sound effects. When it comes to cartoon sound design, Mark and Heather both agree that the medium pushes
角色的身体形状会不自然地拉伸。你知道，这些仅仅是这些角色在视觉上发生的事情的最简单例子。所以在某种程度上，它赋予了你打破规则的许可——当你看到某种东西时，你应该听到什么声音。我真的很喜欢为动画工作，因为我喜欢从零开始用声音构建一个世界，因为动画最棒的部分在于你是从无到有地设计一个世界，一个从未有人听过的世界。我认为音效设计是动画制作过程中极其重要的一部分，
the boundaries of creativity. Characters stretch a naturally out of their body shapes. You know, those are just the simplest examples of visually what's happening with these characters. So in a way, it gives you permission to break the laws of what sound you should hear when you see something. I really like working for animation because I like to build a world with sound from the ground up because in animation the best part is you're designing a world from nothing, a world that no one's ever heard before. And sound design I think is a huge part of
因为除了对话之外没有任何声音。所以你可以负责背景音、音效和拟音，我认为所有这些结合起来，才真正让动画栩栩如生。所以现在有了这么多任何人都能接触到的工具，你真的可以随心所欲地按照你的想象力去设计声音。跟随我们的内心是很重要的，当我们追随内心并以此作为职业时，我们便过上了日复一日的生活……本期《20,000赫兹》由詹姆斯·因特罗卡索（James Introcasso）和达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）撰写并制作，萨姆·施内布利（Sam Schneebley）在 De facto Sound 工作室提供协助。
the process for animation because there's no sound except the talking. So you get to do the backgrounds and sound effects and the fully and I think it all combines to really bring the animation to life. So now there's so many tools that anyone can get their hands on. You're really free to design sound in any way your imagination desires. It's important for us to follow our hearts when we follow our heart and then we make a career out of that. We make a day-to-day This episode of 20,000 Hurtz was written and produced by James Introcasso and Dallas Taylor, with help from Sam Schneebley out of the studios of De facto Sound.
本期节目的剪辑、音效设计和混音由尼克·斯普拉德林（Nick Spradlin）完成。本期节目中的所有音乐均由 Music Bed 提供。你应该订阅《20,000赫兹》。他们是一个很棒的独立播客，我是他们的超级粉丝。你绝对会喜欢的。我们将在网站的shownotes（节目文稿）中提供链接。99% Invisible 是旧金山 KALW 91.7 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心无线电街（Radio Row）。
It was edited, sound-designed, and mixed by Nick Spradlin. All the music in this episode was provided by Music Bed. You should subscribe to 20,000 Hearts. They're a great indie podcast and a big fan. You're totally dig it. We'll have a link on our website in the show notes. 99% Invisible is a project of KALW 91.7 in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown,
我们是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上查找所有这些节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，或@本节目 99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但我们在网络上永远的家是 99PI.org。Radio Topia PRX 本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our forever home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio TepiRX There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集合。请访问radiotopia.fm了解所有这些节目。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，节目官方账号是@99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们在网络上的永远的家是99PI.org。Radio TepiRX 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。